um água tarde todos é um prazer prazer
enorme estar aqui com vocês simplesmente
porque de que lugar que eu estou falando
né lugar de quem está quanto com as
questões da inclusão na escola há
aproximadamente uns 20 anos desde como
eu estava atuando nos programas
educativos aqui tão dinâmico e foi a da
onde surgiu a minha dissertação de
mestrado sobre a inclusão de crianças
nas creches filhos dos servidores é que
da universidade
posteriormente atuando com o pedagogo
agora no laboratório de acessibilidade
dando o atendimento aos alunos com
deficiência dessa universidade
se nós vamos falar de acessibilidade na
universitá di nós não podemos esquecer
de uma trajetória histórica que teve
principalmente do ponto de vista da
legislação
nós sabemos ri com a constituição do
brasil em 88 e inicia o direito ao
acesso de todos à educação
no final dos anos 80 a legislação aponta
cada vez mais na década de 90 nós vamos
ter aqui chamada como teca da inclusão
num primeiro momento com a ldb lei de
diretrizes e base nacional de educação
em 1996 que abre um artigo específico
para a educação especial incluindo a
educação especial desde a educação
infantil chegando a um nível superior ao
mesmo tempo nós vamos ver também na
década de 90 o é a surgindo com direito
às crianças ali
o adolescente vamos ver também
principalmente a tentando sair da década
de 90 e entrando no século 21 o que nós
condenamos hoje com a tecla da
acessibilidade começa com a lei de
acessibilidade
posteriormente em 2006 nós vamos ter a
convenção que nos da onu que nos dá
direito a todas as pessoas de irem para
todos os níveis de educação desde a
infantil até único filho
em 2007 a surgia a educação especial na
perspectiva da educação inclusiva e
começa a inserir dentro desta discussão
grande
o processo de inclusão e um processo não
só de entrada a inserção deste ano um
com deficiência dento do ensino regular
mas principalmente dá acesso e
permanência a esses alunos
é nesse contexto aqui atuando na unicamp
desde 83 até os dias atuais né nós
estamos mexendo com isso nós vamos
acompanhar as políticas de
acessibilidade inclusão da universidade
iniciaram-se praticamente no final da
década de 80 em 2002 sob iniciativa de
manter o tentarem achar nada é desde
titanic com o cubo e outras professoras
aqui com a professora maria tereza natan
então era com projetos com verbas vindas
né da fapesp vieram e de certa forma e
novo não checou chamado
ginaldo oratório de acessibilidade tamta
um campo e no qual ele se propõe
principalmente a dar como o atendimento
aos alunos com deficiência da
universidade
nós vamos vendo ao longo desses 11 anos
que o laboratório de acessibilidade foi
criado aqui no encanto e um crescimento
muito grande da demanda dos alunos com
deficiência num nível superior
talvez isso seja fruto do processo mesmo
de inclusão na educação básica que se
iniciou na década de 90
nas escolas de hoje com a entrada
principalmente o atendimento educacional
especializado pela legislação e toda
escola hoje é ter um atendimento
educacional especializado no setor
específico que de apoio aos alunos com
deficiência em contra turno a a
auto-escola propriamente dito na noite
horário a universo é do horário da aula
destes alunos e esse é ele né instituiu
desde a educação básica aqui o
atendimento educacional especializado
ele passa a haver ou não é
importantíssimo de acolhimento de
adaptação de materiais de inscrição de
recursos de tecnologias assistir assisti
las se isso começa na educação básica
imaginem vocês na década de 90 isto é
extremamente novo entrando é isso na
escola
nós vamos ter agora é principalmente uma
demanda vinda de alunos e cursaram tiver
um pouquinho
de inclusão e estão entrando nas
universidades não me engano e mundo
menor do que outras universidades
privadas tanto que o laboratório de
acessibilidade da unicamp
ele também presta assessoria a outras
universidades no intuito de demonstrar
pós como que é as metodologias nós
utilizamos preta também por exemplo de
uma biografia acadêmica para aqui á o
usuário com deficiência visual possam
usufruir dessa biografia e essa
metodologia de certa forma as suas redes
sem nada em vários lugares
é principalmente porque as pessoas
vinham uma necessidade olha estou nesse
tempo alunos nível superior
amamos com deficiência visual aonde com
transtornos globais envolvimento alunos
com dislexia e empenham para nós
justamente os cães referências né esse
normal nós temos praticamente já 11 anos
atuando com isso nós vemos que na
universidade
nós encontramos aquilo que o autor
sasaki nos fala sobre custos anos seis
visitas né de acessibilidade
primeiro que nós sabemos perfeitamente
tem sem a possibilidade de vir ea tentar
que a acessibilidade e telefônica nem um
ano pode usufruir então os prédios
começam a ser modificados
em vista dessa questão da acessibilidade
comunicacional conteúdos nossos usuários
eles nos colocam não adianta
transformados impressa mente com várias
faixas vários lembretes pobres se eu não
tiver condições
direitos então na comunicação
mesmo que ela esteja impressa mesmo que
ela seja online
ela tem necessariamente está assistindo
as pessoas para terem todo poder
participar dessa vida alheia
então lá e também de escolha de
softwares hardwares impressoras brais
que fosse clicam auxílio alguns
professores na necessidade deles
divulgação de algum evento de algum
evento que possa ser conduzido num
formato em outros formatos como formato
lembrar mesmo assim também nós
percebemos que precisa haver
acessibilidade instrucional é
instrumental principalmente nos
instrumentos porque mesmo que nós
tenhamos lá no laboratório de
acessibilidade tecnologias assistivas
com histórias leitores nem todo usuário
usufrui da mesma forma do mesmo
equipamento precisa de uma certa com o
olhar
vamos dizer assim mais um olhar do
fracional na forma com esse aluno
aprende esse equipamento como é que ele
utiliza para ver se esse realmente o
melhor equipamento para ele as condições
de estudo que ele vai efetivar nós vamos
ver também a acessibilidade metodológica
é criar métodos que nos possibilitem dar
condições para que as pessoas possam
usufruir isso mesmo assim dentro dessa
cena dessas possibilidades nós
percebemos uma que é mais importante que
é a sensibilidade atitudinal se não se
pode ficar nessas questões de
preconceito com o aluno com a pessoa com
deficiência e se passa a ser a nossa
maior na ilha
podemos ter equipamentos porque podemos
ter softwares hardwares que nos
possibilitam dar a
adequações passeia questão antes do
original ela não é com cinto
por isso a minha mensagem final deixando
aqui com vocês é uma atitude é que traz
o benefício a outro é atitude de um
considerá lo como pessoa um ser humano
como animal com seus direitos como
cidadão brasileiro e é isso que nós
procuramos fazer para os laboratórios de
acessibilidade muito brilho